okay good
welcome everyone to this optimization
session so we have a great list of talks
and we're going to start
with kevin tian so kevin if you can
share your slides
so the format i recall for everybody
eight minutes talk if you have a
clarification question feel free to ask
and then at the end of the you know five
eight minutes talk
we'll have a panel session with where we
can ask all the questions you want
take it away kevin
awesome thanks so much ted um and hey
everyone i hope you're enjoying itcs
uh my name is kevin and i'm excited to
share with you our recent work
uh title is relative viciousness and
extra creative methods and a direct
recipient for
acceleration and this is joint work with
michael b cohen from mit and my advisor
aaron sidford from stanford
cool um so in our paper we study uh
algorithms for a broad family of
problems called solving variational
inequalities or vi's
in monotone operators um and don't worry
if you don't know
what these words mean i'll define them
very shortly so if i had to briefly
summarize the main takeaways of our work
they'd be as follows um we show that a
more fine-grained analysis
of existing algorithms for solving vis
based on bounding a new parameter we
call
relative luxuriousness um yields
improved rates of convergence in various
interesting applications
as compared to the standard predictions
of vi theory
so um notably a number of custom
analyses for solving special cases of
bis
uh which yield rates not predicted by
the standard vi theory
and these analyses may appear somewhat
disparate at a glance
they actually all fall under our
framework and they can be explained
um by this single definition so the
resulting proofs are usually quite
straightforward and
amount to a few applications of koji
schwartz so we hope this
demystifies these previous analyses
um so one example of a special vi
algorithm i'll focus on
is uh accelerated gradient descent and
this algorithm
was introduced in the 80s and as a
landmark results in optimization theory
um but it's proof is described by
experts as quite mysterious
we also define an expected variant of
our definition and we show that a new
analysis of stochastic bi algorithms
yields improved rates for structured
problems and
more fine-grained randomized accelerated
results
and finally a third application capture
back framework is approximation
algorithms for undirectedness flow
um we show that this recent area
convexity framework proposed by sherman
for this problem
um is in fact recovered by a fine grain
local variant of our
um of our definition so uh for this
abridged version of this talk i won't
have time to get into too many details
but i wanted to mention the style i
tried to capture with the full talk um
so i really tried to
emphasize giving an intuitive
introduction to extra gradient methods
and the talk contains a full novel proof
of acceleration from first principles
um following our framework so if you
haven't seen that before it might be
kind of cool
um and if you have a chance to listen to
the full version we'd uh really
appreciate it
cool so um i'll start by describing the
problem family we study
so a vi is parameterized by a monotone
operator g
from its set to its dual um which
satisfies
the displayed condition so this is what
it means for gdp monotone
um and informally it forces the results
of the operator on two points x and y
to be aligned with the direction between
the two points
and we're only going to consider two
examples of monotone operators in this
talk the first is just the
when g is the gradient of a convex
function and the second is when
g is what we call the gradient operator
of a convex concave function on two
blocks
so now we'll define variational
inequalities uh in short solving a vi
and a monotone g
just asks to find a point x star such
that the inner product between g of x
star
and x star minus x for any x in the
domain is non-positive
so just briefly in the case of example
one
this just amounts to minimizing the
convex function and in example two
the solution of the vi is just the
saddle point or nash equilibrium of the
convex concave function
okay so um i won't go into this too much
here but the proofs that these operators
are really monotone
and that the solutions to uh to the eyes
are what i claim they were
just directly followed from applying
convexity or concavity
cool so um we'll basically only be
discussing one family of algorithms for
solving vis which is collectively
referred to as extra gradient methods um
these methods apply to a vi in an
operator g
and are driven by regularizer r so the
pair g comma r
just defines um the algorithm
and typically when analyzing these
extracted methods the regularizer r
is assumed to be strongly convex which
is basically a strength to be
a strengthening of normal convexity so
normal complexity allows for zero
curvature
in a specified norm and strong chunk of
x just means it has some positive
curvature
and um when the when the regularizer is
strongly convex
uh namorovsky showed that when the
operator g is lipschitz
then the method converges at a rate
roughly lambda over t
where lambda is the liquidus parameter
and
um under the strong under the stronger
assumption that the operator g is not
only a strong
monotone but it's also strongly monotone
um the method converges at the displayed
rate which is exponential and lambda
over m so this is sort of like a
condition number for monotone operators
okay um so under these minimal
assumptions these rates were
shown to be tight even in the euclidean
norm case so in some sense extra
gradient methods are optimal for solving
vis in monotone operators
um however for a number of structured
vis it's known that you can actually
beat the predictions of the standard
theory and this sort of motivated our
talk so um perhaps the most famous
example
of an improvement is when the vi is just
uh in the gradient of a convex function
so as a reminder this just means you're
trying to minimize the function and um
nestorov's accelerated gradient descent
obtains roughly a
quadratic improvement upon the
predictions of standard extravagant
analyses
uh for this special case okay so that's
one to keep in the back of your head
um another interesting example of a
structured case that we think is
interesting to a tcs
audience is l infinity aggression and
this setup has applications to
uh approximate max flow so obtaining one
over t rates of convergence for this
problem
uh with that worst dependence on
dimension uh was a notorious obstacle
until a breakthrough work of sherman in
2017.
following a new framework called area
convexity
okay so um finally a few other mysteries
around extra gradient methods so it
remains unclear
what kinds of structured vi's allowed
for one over t rates of convergence
which would match their uh deterministic
counterparts oh sorry biased stochastic
methods which would match the
deterministic counterparts
and um in another line of work a
perspective notice optimism was proposed
to analyze these algorithms
two minutes sure um okay so the main
conceptual contribution of our paper is
a
new condition characterizing the
convergence rate of extra gradient
methods
uh beyond this standard setup of a
licious operator and a strong complexer
and this characterization boils down to
a simple to verify relationship between
g and r
and it basically captures the rates of
these structure diseases we mentioned
which were previously only attainable by
tailored analyses
um i won't have time to go too much into
uh what external methods are but maybe
i'll talk about it if there's time for
questions
um but i'll briefly describe um the
motivation for our condition
uh the main idea is that um
uh we we view extra graded methods as a
discretization of a
idealized method called prox point and
we directly characterize their
performance in terms of the
discrimination error so
basically if the discretization error if
lambda is large enough
the step size parameter is large enough
so that the discrimination error is
non-positive
um then we say uh
g is lambda relative relative ellipses
in r and if you look at the
discrimination error we just
rewrote that um into a condition
um and it turns out that this uh this
definition is strong enough to capture
many of the structured examples i
mentioned before including randomized
variants
um so the main takeaway is you don't
really need a new analysis for ev
for each of these separate types of
problems you can just directly bound
this uh this parameter lambda
um which characterizes how relatively
lipschitz the operator is
will stick to the regularizer um and
cool so thanks so much for listening to
our presentation and if you want to know
more i
really encourage you to check out the
full version of the talk of the paper
i'm also more than happy to answer your
questions offline there's a number of
exciting open directions i want to take
uh we're excited to take this work
and we want to fully understand the
power of executing methods great
thanks a lot kevin i think there will be
lots of questions uh during the panel
session
um but for now let's move on to the next
talk
on major majorizing measures for the
optimizer
do we have a speaker for this talk yeah
i can share my screen let me try the
phone
all right can you see it yeah yeah you
can start
all right uh hi everyone so this talk
will be about the gaussian processors
uh my name is makran and this is a joint
work with sander both daniel the douche
and
older so gaussian process
is just a collection of joint legal
standard variables indexed by some
subset
x in our d we'll assume that they're
centered mean zero
and we're interested in computing the
expected supremum of such a process
so this is a very natural quantity that
arises in a lot of
places for example if you look at the
gaussian process
which is given by taking a set of
extreme parts of a polytope and
the gaussian process is given by taking
a inner product with a standard gaussian
and a vector with every point in x
then the expected supremum is called the
gaussian width of this point set and
it's very useful in dimensionality
reduction in many other places
another example comes from random
matrices so if you take a gaussian
random matrix and
take x to be the set of all points uh
particularly in norm 1
and the gaussian process is given by the
quadratic form
xax and the expected supreme of this
process is exactly the
expected operating norm which is very
very
useful in a lot of places
that says it should not be surprising
that it has tons of applications
let's look at one that will be relevant
for us also which is gordon's theorem
so this is a powerful dimensionality
reduction statement
so points at x lives on the unit sphere
now and the gordon's theorem
gives you a linear map that maps it to m
dimensional space where m is about
width square and this projection
preserves all norms
and this is useful for dimensionality
reduction compressed sensing and so on
and it generalizes the well-known
johnson linder strauss
lemma which probably most of you are
aware of it uh
where m is about the log of the
cardinality of x but here
x could even be infinite
okay so now that i've probably convinced
you that gaussian processors are
important
one can ask how can we prove bounce
unexpected supremum which is usually
very difficult
so one very nice characterization of
this thing was given by sudakov we
showed that it's uniquely characterized
if you define distances between two
points and the point set x by
the standard deviation of the random
variable z x minus zy
so for example in this simple gaussian
process this metric is exactly the
euclidean metric
but this can differ in for other
processes
so now that uh we know that it's
uniquely characterized by this metric
and can ask if there's some simple
quantity
depending on the metric that we can
compute that will give us
you know nice upper and lower bounds
two very nice upper and lower bounds
that are relatively easy to prove
or in terms of the size of the epsilon
net of
your point set x so an epsilon net is
just a minimum set of points so that
every point is within a distance epsilon
from
it some point in the net and here
epsilon ranges over various scales from
zero to let's say the diameter of x
the problem with both of these bounds is
that they are not tight
so the gap can be arbitrarily large in
either case
and sort of uh motivated by this for
nick tried to improve the upper bound
and he proved this upper bound that's
called the majorizing measures bond
which is stated in terms of this
optimization problem so you have
minimum overall probability measures
then you have the supreme number all
points in x and there's some weird
looking quantity
uh the integral of square root log of 1
over the measure of
ball of radius x around epsilon that's a
lot to parse so maybe for intuition in
this short talk i can only give you a
very handy very intuition that sort of
new selects uh that measure view it
selects
sort of a weighted epsilon net a
different scale and in the end you just
want to optimize over the best possible
mu
so this is in some sense a strengthening
of
the upper bound in terms of epsilon x
and sort of you can use this uh
weighted epsilon net to define a tree
structure on the metric space
uh that we call a chaining tree and this
gives you an upper bound the value of
the process
and this majorizing measures found is
essentially the minimum value of any
such tree
now for any conjecture that this
measurizing measures bound with type and
this was proven by telegram in a very
influential work
and it's called the majorizing measures
theorem now so i mean this
exactly tells you that expected supremum
is up to constant factors
equal to the majorizing measures found
which is a very uh
nice characterization of gaussian
processes
and the the main innovation of telegram
to prove this was to develop a dual
notion of
packing trees so these give lower bounds
on the expected supreme just as chaining
trees
gave upper bound sort of
but the the original proof was
considered fairly difficult and uh
over the years many simpler different
proofs have been obtained
and in this talk we'll give another one
which i think adds a lot of insight at
least to us
so to say what we do let us
revisit the statement of the majorizing
measures so
it's you can break it down into two
parts the first part is that
the value of these chaining and packing
trees which are only defined in terms of
the metric
they give you upper and lower bounds so
this is a fairly easy statement to prove
the second part is the difficult part
which is
sort of a combinatorial min max theorem
it says
you know the minimum value of a chain
entry and the maximum value of packing
trees they are
almost equal there is some kind of
strong duality between them
and our main contribution so first of
all this
already separates the role of matrix
space from gaussian process which makes
it clean
the main contribution we just give proof
of the combinatorial
min max theorem using convex duality and
rounding
so as uh so the main
punch line is sort of that this duality
between chaining and packing trees this
is in fact the convex
uh consequence of convex duality so
there is a convex program that looks in
the background
which gives rise to this and as an
application we give
like a deterministic algorithms for
various things one of them is the
projection in goddess theorem
so i will not go into that here so
let me just briefly tell you where the
convex program pops up
so let's if you look at this majorizing
measures bound this is essentially a
convex program because root log one over
p is convex
on a large part of the interval zero to
one so
you can ignore the technicality which
can be fixed
and now if you take a primal measurement
which is a solution to this program you
can round it
to a chaining tree which gives you an
upper bound on the process
so this is already proven by telegram
and which show that
if you take the dual of this context
program then you can round it to packing
tree
after simplifications and this gives you
a lower bound
and the beautiful fact is the sort of
fairly easily convex duality sort of
implies
in a nice way that these two uh the
value of chaining and packing trees
are constant factors away from each
other it gives us the combinatorial
element max theorem
and uh yeah
and i should mention that sort of the
rounding is the difficult part of this
proof
uh apart from you know relating the
uh primal and dual batches for the
simplified dual
because if you have a tree then
obtaining a measure that satisfies
that gives you optimal bounds for these
problems is fairly easy
and lastly to mention that this proof is
fairly algorithmic because
you just want to solve an optimization
problem and then and round it so this
gives
us an algorithmic way to obtain all of
these objects
and to compute other applications so
that's all i have to say
we'll stop here excellent thank you very
much
uh great talk so next
uh we're gonna be talking about low rank
approximation and i think cameron is
giving the talk um yeah let me
share my screen
all right is that looking okay yeah that
looks perfect
you can go ahead great so i'm gonna be
talking about
um simple methods uh for
the masked low rank approximation
problem this is joint work with chris
musco and david woodruff
so we're looking at the rank
approximation i have a
n by n matrix a and i want to
approximate it by an n by n matrix l
that only has right k
and we typically do this to compress a
or to denoise it there's lots of
applications of it
a common metric that i try to minimize
when i'm looking for l is i try to
minimize its distance to a in the
forbidious form so i try to minimize
the sum over all the entries in my
matrix of
the the value on a minus the value on l
squared so this is the squared for
benious form difference between these
matrices
what we're looking at today is the
mastable rank approximation problem
which
arises in the case when you want to
perform low rank approximation when some
of the entries in a are either unknown
or they're corrupted or for whatever
reason they don't follow low rank
structure and you just want to ignore
these entries
so we can formalize this using a binary
mask
matrix i have this matrix w
it's an n by n binary matrix it has ones
on the entries that i care about or that
i think follow the lowering structure
and it has zeros on the entries that i
don't care about or are corrupted that i
generally want to ignore
and now instead of minimizing the
distance between a and
l where l is a lowering matrix i'm going
to minimize the distance between a and l
where i only consider
the forbiddenious arm restricted to the
ones in the mask
so i'm writing this as the forbidious
norm of w hadamard product with a minus
l
where this is just equal to the sum of
all entries where w is equal to one
of the squared difference between a and
l on those entries
okay so that's mass loading
approximation
this arises in a lot of applications
one example is low rank plus diagonal
approximation often there's there are
matrices that are well approximated by a
low rank component
plus a diagonal component this comes up
in factor analysis which is basically
pca with different noise variances in
each dimension it's used for kernel
matrix approximation lots of different
places
and the reason this is basically an
instance of mass flow rank approximation
is that if i have this optimal low rank
factor l
then i know exactly what the optimal
diagonal matrix should be
i should just sort of correct the
diagonal of l to be equal to the
diagonal of a so if i know l
d should just be equal to the diagonal
of a minus the diagonal of l
so optimizing the finding the best
flooring plus the diagonal approximation
in the forbiddenious form
is equivalent to solving mastodoric
approximation
where you have a mask matrix that tells
you just like ignore the diagonal of the
matrix
and then approximate everything else on
the matrix so in this case our mask
matrix w is kind of like an inverted
identity it's zeros on the diagonal
and one's off the dag that's just one
example there's lots of other examples
um low rank plus sparse approximation
also known as robust pca
which is very well studied it's used for
for example for background separation
low rank plus banded approximation low
rank plus block
sparse or block diagonal approximations
all these different problems can be put
into the same
massive rank approximation framework and
i'll note that
masculine approximation is really
closely related to matrix completion
matrix completion is sort of
where i'm given a matrix and i'm missing
some entries and i want to fill in
the missing entries often i do this by
computing a lowering approximation that
matches the instant entries that i've
seen
but the goals are very different so in
matrix completion you're trying to fill
in your missing entries
in mastering approximation we don't
necessarily care about the missing
entries we're just trying to approximate
our matrix on the entries that we have
or the entries that we care about that
we think follow lowrance structure
so they're kind of fundamentally
different problems but definitely very
related
all right so what's known about this
problem maybe not surprisingly it's np
hard in general
there are some special cases like this
low rank plus diagonal case
the hardness is unresolved polynomial
time algorithms aren't known but they're
not ruled out
a lot of variants can be solved provably
via convex relaxation or alternating
minimization
invariably these types of proofs make
different types of assumptions they
either make incoherence assumptions on
the matrix they
sort of that its masses randomly spread
out or random mask assumptions like if
the mask is sparse
maybe you assume that its entries are in
random locations and a lot of these
proofs kind of follow
in there they're very closely related to
the matrix completion literature
um there are provable approximation
algorithms with no assumptions like this
for the more general weighted low rank
approximation problem where your mask
isn't necessarily binary but is just
general real value mask um and
yeah so there's probable approximation
algorithms but they have exponential
dependencies in the rank and the error
parameter and other parameters
and what we're looking for is uh fully
polynomial time algorithms
so our contributions is we give
polynomial time
by criteria approximations for the mass
low rank approximation problem
and what this means is we give a poly
time algorithm that outputs
a matrix l prime whose rank is equal to
k prime
k prime is going to be bigger than our
target rank that's what this buy
criteria means
so it's a little bit bigger than our
target rank but we get a good error so
the um error a minus l prime times our
mass
is less than the opt for the best rank k
approximation on our non-massed entries
plus some small additive error epsilon
times the forbidious norm of our matrix
so the real question then becomes this
is a good error bound but what is this k
prime we ideally want k prime or by
criteria to rank
to be as close as possible to the true
right k so we're sort of
getting an actual good approximation to
our matrix
and um the sort of like maybe
interesting point of this paper or like
at least we thought this was kind of
surprising for us initially is that
we're able to obtain by criteria
approximation where k
prime depends on a very natural
complexity measure of this mask matrix w
um this mass matrix w is an n by n
boolean matrix
so we can view it as the communication
matrix of
um a two player communication matrix of
a boolean function that takes two inputs
one is
both are in our bit strings in log n so
think about
the rows and columns of this matrix are
indexed by login length bit strings
we view it as a communication matrix and
our rank k prime is going to depend on
the randomized communication complexity
of that communication problem so
the easier it is to communicate that
matrix the lower by criteria rank we're
going to get
so just as an example like in this low
rank plus diagonal case that i discussed
you don't care about approximate matrix
on the diagonal you only care about the
off diagonal
so your mass matrix is all zeros on the
diagonal and all ones on the off
diagonal
that's the communication matrix for the
inequality problem
other problems like low rank plus banded
relates to
the communication matrix of a variant of
the greater than problem
um and so for all the problems that
we look at the by criteria rank that we
derive from this communication velocity
connection
um ends up being k times poly log n over
epsilon where that poly is usually very
low poly
so we get pretty good bicar tier
approximation results via this
connection to communication complexity
um so our guarantees like beyond just
the results we get our guarantees are
achieved by a really simple polynomial
time heuristic
um okay thanks i'm sort of the one time
so i won't
okay so let me go yeah so our guarantees
are achieved by a very simple polynomial
time heuristic
and this is something that's used a lot
for example in the matrix completion
literature
all you do is you set you let l prime be
the best rank k
prime approximation to a times w meaning
you zero out the
entries you don't care about and then
you just take the best
approximation of this matrix this you
can do very quickly with an svd or
there's lots of fast approximation
algorithms
um and so i don't have enough time to
sort of explain why does this algorithm
give
by criteria approximation that has like
rank
related to the communication complexity
but i'll say very very roughly
what we do is we construct an explicit
rank a prime approximation
that is zero on all entries that we
don't care about
and we construct this by basically
tiling our mask matrix
by using combinatorial rectangles and we
know we don't have too many of those
coming into our rectangles if that mass
matrix has low
communication complexity we then show
that this heuristic only does better
than that construction so
the existence of a good communication
protocol for our matrix
certifies the accuracy of this heuristic
and so sorry that i ran out of time but
please check out the full paper
um to see that connection more clearly
it takes a lot
great thanks cameron
again we will keep the questions for the
end of the session and next we have
agnostic learning with
unknown utilities
i think you need to stop sharing
perfect um yeah is my screen
visible like i mean yes yes
yeah perfect go ahead
hi hi everyone i'm kush bhatia and i'll
be presenting our work on agnostic
learning with unknown utilities
uh this is joint work with peter
bartlett ankar dragon and jacob
steinhardt
a classical decision problem one often
begins with a data set consisting of
n data points and the objective in most
scenarios is to learn a classifier which
predicts label wise correctly from
context vectors x within this paradigm
most works if not all implicitly assume
that all mistakes are equally costly
and that each scenario x is equally
important
in reality though this is often not the
case so
for instance if you consider the
classification system which is designed
for a self-driving car
uh the cost of mispredicting a roast
roadside post office box versus that of
missing out on a stop sign can actually
be very different
furthermore consider the two scenarios
shown in the picture
one where a person is crossing the road
and the other where a person is walking
far away from the roadside
clearly identifying the person correctly
is far more important in the first case
as compared to the second one so
our work in our work we actually posit
that each decision taken by the learner
has a context dependent utility
and a key characteristic of this utility
function is that it is unknown to the
learner a priori before the task begins
now given this insight the question that
we ask in our work
is how does one model this decision
problem with an
unknown and arbitrary utility function
so in order to answer this question our
work proposes this framework of agnostic
learning with unknown utilities
which actually generalizes the classical
agnostic learning framework
so formally the learner is presented
with a data set consisting of n data
points where each x i
is sampled from some unknown
distribution d
we denote by script f the class of
decision making functions which map from
the space of covariates to the space of
decision
decisions we further denote by u star
the true
underlying utility function which is
unknown to the learner
and lastly there is an information
article which with which the learner can
interact and get more information about
the different decisions and the
underlying utility you start
so as i've mentioned earlier our
framework moves away from placing
any assumption on this underlying
utility function you start
and just posits that the decision
function can only be selected from this
class script f
given this framework the objective of
the learner is to output a function f
hat
which has small excess risk when
evaluated on this
true unknown utility function u star
now given this setup the question here
is what should be this information
oracle
uh this article should actually be
powerful enough to make
any kind of learning feasible but should
also not be too overly complicated for
so that like human experts are not able
to answer these queries
so let's jump into this information
oracle now and
the first contender for such an
information oracle is the value article
so in this uh given a context x and a
decision the human expert provides the
exact value of the underlying utility
function when evaluated on
on this context decision pair however
note that this utility function can
actually be quite complex
and it makes it hard for human experts
to accurately provide these value
judgments
and this actually makes it infeasible to
deploy such an oracle in practice
so on the other hand it is often easier
for humans to provide comparative
evaluation based on these utilities
so for instance one can query the human
with a context and a pair of decisions
and just
ask which one of those two has a higher
utility when evaluated on the true
utility you start
such comparative feedback is is actually
very limited in the kind of information
it provides to the learner and
i'm just going to explain that with the
help of a very small example
so consider these two classifiers f1 and
f2 and
observe that both of them make the same
number of mistakes
f1 mispredicts x3 and f2 mispredicts x1
note that just by interacting with the
comparison oracle
no learner will be able to understand
the trade-off between these different
mistakes
and as a much stronger statement one can
actually show that the excess risk for
any algorithm
which interacts only with the comparison
oracle will actually be order one
so while this oracle is actually easy to
implement on the human side it's
actually information theoretically
limited
now just to go to the other extreme one
can imagine a
very powerful oracle uh which we call
the infinite comparison oracle
and this oracle takes in two functions
f1 and f2
and the human expert outputs which of
these has a higher utility when
evaluated on the underlying distribution
t
and note that this article is actually
it's
very powerful and any learning algorithm
can actually figure out which is the
best function f
in the function class script f by
interacting with this article
however it actually places all the
burden of
learning on the human expert it's
effectively asking them to make to
compare decisions across an infinite
number of contexts
so thus while this historical is
information theoretically optimal
uh this article is practically
infeasible to implement
in order to overcome these limitations
of existing mechanism
our work proposes a new type of
comparison oracle which we call the k
comparisons
this this type of information feedback
actually interpolates between the
vanilla comparisons and the infinite
comparisons
so in this the human expert is given a
bucket of k different context vectors
x 1 to x k and two sets of associated
decision vectors
and the human here is required to
compare these two bundles
and output which of these two has a
higher combined utility
uh observe that by setting k equals to 1
and k equals to infinity we can we can
recover back the vanilla comparisons and
the infinite comparisons
and one thing to note here is that as
this order k
of the comparison increases it it
actually gets cognitively harder and
harder for the human to
actually provide this kind of feedback
so going forward in this talk we'll
focus on this problem of agnostic
learning with unknown utilities where
this information article is the k
comparison oracle
with this setup i'll i'll briefly
describe our main algorithm
this is simply a two-stage plug-in
estimator
in the first step uh in the first step
the algorithm obtains the estimates you
had on the sample data points using the
k comparisons
and in the next step it outputs the
empirical utility maximizer in the class
script f
in our work we actually study the
statistical properties of this plugin
estimator and show that it's minimax
optimal
in the course of our analysis we also
uncover an interesting accuracy
elicitation trade-off
so as the order k of this oracle
increases
the error decreases at a rate of 1 over
k as can be seen from the upper bound
theorem
however as we had noted earlier
increasing this error actually
increases increasing this order makes it
harder and harder for the human to
provide
these responses more accurately thus by
varying this value of k
one can cover an entire spectrum of this
trade off
so just to conclude our work actually
formalizes a class of supervised
learning problems wherein the underlying
utility functions is unknown to the
learner a priori
and we study a very natural plug-in
estimator and show that it's
mini-max optimal
that's it excellent thank you very much
last we're gonna talk about quantum
speed up
and gradient descent
thanks let me share my screen yeah
and then recall that after this talk we
have the panel session and we can ask
all the questions that we want to the
speakers
yeah looks good robin you can go ahead
all right thank you um okay so my
my talk's gonna be uh answering the
question can quantum computers speed up
gradient descent
joint work with uh ankit garg bernit
nitripali and suhail
so there's going to be a high level talk
i mean partly because it's a
eight-minute talk and partly because i
don't want to assume that the audience
knows either quantum computing or
optimization so okay let's start with
the question
um and i mean well this is part of the
optimization session so at least i
i assume that the audience would know
what gradient descent is if you don't
it's not a big deal
but like the specific details of the
algorithm are not relevant for this talk
but it's all you need to keep in mind is
some algorithm for minimizing functions
in rn
okay so this was a question motivates
this work
and if you think about this question for
for a few minutes you might you might
realize like what does this question
even mean what does it what does it mean
for a quantum algorithm to speed up a
classical algorithm
it's not clear this question's
meaningful so for example does shore's
algorithm speed up the best classical
algorithm for factoring numbers
i mean as far as i know schwarz
algorithm is just a quantum algorithm
that solves the factorization problem
but
it's not a speed up of the classical
algorithm and it doesn't look like the
classical algorithm at all
so you have to be a little careful in
formalizing this question
and this is like a naive way of
formalizing which is not very helpful
which says that the quantum algorithm
should do exactly what gradient descent
does basically should output the same
sequence of points the gradient descent
would output
in its uh you know
quest for finding the minimum of this
function but this is not really helpful
because we're kind of forcing the
quantum algorithm to do exactly the same
thing that the classical algorithm would
do so
uh i think there's another great look at
the question what is meaningful to ask
is
we can say quantum computers solve a
specific problem faster than gradient
descent so like in the shores algorithm
example
we can say quantum computers solve the
factorization problem faster than any
known classical algorithm
so that's how we choose to formalize
this question and so what we want to do
is we want to find
a problem that can be solved by gradient
descent and furthermore for which
gradient descent is the optimal
classical algorithm because otherwise
even classical algorithms would
solve that problem faster than gradient
descent so we want to take a problem
that somehow characterizes gradient
descent like it
uh really captures the power of gradient
descent and then we'll ask can quantum
algorithms solve this problem faster
fortunately there's a very canonical
problem that does this and if you
don't care for the motivation on this
slide you can just forget about this
motivation we can just skip to the
problem so the problem we study is this
problem called first order black box
convex optimization
if you've read any textbooks on this
topic like this problem will appear in
like the first
two or three chapters so there's there's
a bunch of good textbooks there's one by
nestrom
and seb also has a very nice monograph
on this subject and it's like in chapter
two
of his book so this is the problem for
starter black box conflicts opposition
you're given
a convex function in rn f it's lipschitz
constant
we we know as atmos g uh if you don't
know what the electric console is
just think of it as some upper bound on
how quickly the function varies so it's
an upper bound on its derivative so the
function doesn't wiggle too fast in a
small
space and we want to minimize this
function on
b zero comma r this is the unit or not
the unit ball but the ball of radius r
around the origin
and so x star is this minimizer and you
don't have to output x star
you just have to output an approximation
to x star so you want to find some point
x such that f
x minus f of x star is less than epsilon
and the quantity we're
trying to minimize is the number of
times you evaluate the function and its
gradient
so that's the only thing we're trying to
minimize just how many evaluations you
make of
f and grad f okay so first let's talk
about classical algorithms for this
problem
um so if you notice in the problem
there's actually four
different free parameters ngr and
epsilon but it turns out that
truly there's only two parameters and
that's because there's some freedom in
the function so we can rescale the
domain and range
and that won't really change the problem
so two of the parameters are really
spurious so you should think of this
problem as having only two parameters
n and gr over epsilon
okay so now we can ask what is the
optimal classical algorithm
and it turns out there's two optimal
classical algorithms
um which you can neatly call the
dimension
independent algorithm or dimension
dependent algorithm so the dimension
independent algorithm
has complexity gr over epsilon squared
and gradient descent for example will do
this
and dimension dependent algorithms
there's many of them and they have
complexity
order n log g r or epsilon
okay what do i mean by these are both
optimal what i mean is
you look at these two expressions and
whichever one is smaller
that's you can use that algorithm of
course and that's actually optimal
and so for example when n is very large
so it's polynomially larger than gr over
epsilon
then it's clear that you should use
gradient descent that's the smaller
bound and in that regime that's the best
algorithm
so what do i mean formally let me just
um
recap this is the formal problem first
order black box convex optimization
gradient descent solves this problem
with gr or epsilon squared queries
independent of n doesn't matter and what
can be shown is that no classical
algorithm
even if it uses randomization can solve
this problem faster
when n is large so we're in this
dimension independent settings we're
thinking of n as being polynomially
larger than
g r epsilon uh no classical algorithm
could do better
so in other words radiant descent is the
optimal algorithm okay so now we have
this very nice
clean cut problem which gradient descent
solves optimally and now we can ask can
quantum computers solve this problem
faster
so that's the problem we consider in
this work um
because i don't want to assume people
are understand quantum algorithms i'll
just
leave it at this level of detail
formally i'll have to explain exactly in
what sense do
quantum algorithms have access to f and
grad f so if you know what quantum
algorithms are
uh all i mean is you have access to f
and grad f in in superposition that
means you can make superposition queries
to these two
uh functions okay so that's
that's the that's the problem we set up
and
one thing to do is we already know that
classical algorithms need
to take you know graphs on square
queries to solve this problem so there
is some
hard instance that appears in these cl
in this classical or burner so we can
ask well can quantum computers do better
at least on that hard
instance right so that's always a good
first place to start because you start
out with
the hardest instance for the classical
algorithm and with your quantum
algorithm so instead of starting out
trying to solve all instances faster
just start out with this and we we look
through the literature to find like the
simplest classical lore band and since
we could find and we
we we came up with a nice one that we
don't think appears in the
literature anywhere but it's very clean
so let me let me just tell you what it
is
so as i said there's there's two
spurious parameters so we can just set
and r to one with our loss of generality
so there's only one parameter epsilon
and think of n as being
arbitrarily large and i'll just choose
it to be one or epsilon squared for this
foreground
and it turns out that you can choose
this family of functions f
z parameterized by an n-bit string z
and it's just a very simple function
it's just basically a max of the n
standard basis vectors x i with a random
sign in front of them like a plus minus
one but we don't know
and it turns out and the proof is not
hard at all we include this in our paper
it's pretty slick proof shows that any
classic algorithm even with
randomization
must make one over epsilon squared
queries and this is optimal of course
it's it's matched by gradient descent
and the so the first thing that we
observed is there is actually a quantum
speed up
for this family of functions so there's
family functions it's hard for classical
algorithms
you can actually solve it with one or
epsilon queries in the quantum world
and it uses a very non-trivial algorithm
a quantum algorithm called bellows
algorithm for combinatorial group
testing so it's not using grover's
algorithm which is the usual suspect
when you see quadratic speedups
um okay yeah so so quantum algorithms
can solve this family of functions for
the quadratic speedup so so here's a
here's a recap of what's going on so
there's a hard family of functions that
appears in this classical lower bound
and in the lower bound it's pretty easy
to show that you need one or epsilon
squared queries
to solve this problem um to solve this
first order black box convex
minimization problem
on this family of functions but on this
family of functions
quantum algorithms can solve the problem
faster with the quadratic speed up
uh you know so it's one or epsilon this
or one epsilon squared
and so you know obviously so the
question is can you always get a
quadratic speed up
for this problem or was this just kind
of a coincidence that
we just found a nice set of um
functions that was hard for classical
algorithms but doesn't
it but it's not hard for quantum
mechanics
and the main contribution of this work
is uh well
actually well this was just a
coincidence i guess there exists a
different family of hard functions for
which
even quantum algorithms must make robin
just a clarification
question if instead of taking the linear
function random on the hypercube
you were taking it random on the sphere
would the quantum speed up still be
possible
no the quantum speed up doesn't persist
but we also don't know how to show that
that function's
hard for quantum oh i see
okay interesting yeah
interesting okay but what do you think
i suspect it's hard but that our
techniques will not be able to show it
okay so maybe
i should let you conclude and then we
can move to the panel discussion
so maybe one minute for the conclusion
okay
so right so there exists a different
family of heart functions that we
constructed
um for which and we proved the lower
bound so you know the conclusion of this
talk is that well okay there's no
quantum speed up in this setting the
setting of first order black box
conflicts opposition over gradient
descent
and since i have a few seconds let me
say a little bit about what what was the
difficult part here
uh well first we had to find a different
family of heart functions this is this
was not the hard part
uh this kind of many families of heart
functions have been studied as
sub-alluded to you can take random
vectors on the sphere
but we need some more stuff but it turns
out there's a lot of
there's a literature on improving lower
bounds for this problem in the setting
of parallel queries where you're allowed
to make
randomized queries in parallel and
they've constructed this literature um
has constructed a lot of crazy functions
and you know one of them turned out to
be useful for us
so that was on the convex optimization
side we borrowed heavily from this
parallel lower bounds
technology on the quantum side the
difficult part is that
uh almost all standard quantum load band
techniques are developed for
boolean functions so when you query an
oracle that's just an n-bit string
here the problem is we're creating this
this thing f and grad f which are you
know
n real numbers for example and
the techniques aren't suited well suited
for this kind of stuff so
this is part of what made lower bound
really hard to prove and finally we use
this technique called the hybrid
argument which if you're familiar with
quantum load bonds is one of the
earliest ones
that was ever used and that's all i want
to say
all right great thanks a lot robin so
now we move to the
panel discussion part of the session so
the floor is open to ask
a question about any of the talks that
we've seen
and we're maybe going to start with a
question from the audience
that was asked by mayank
bhaskar it's a question for cameron
so mayank is asking if i understand
correctly what happens in practice i
mean it's a very clean heuristic that
you have
do you know what happens in practice
with k prime can you take k prime close
to k
what does it look like um
yeah that's a good question i'm not
really sure so we haven't really messed
around with it too much in practice
this the heuristic's super simple it's
not doing anything smart it's just
zeroing out
the mast entries and then doing a rank
approximation so i think if you drive k
prime close to k it's not going to do
well
so you really do need that by criteria
for it to do well but i don't really
know
exactly how big k prime really needs to
be
cool um
okay maybe i can ask a question to kevin
uh and again for the audience feel free
to you know speak up in that question
so kevin you talked about relative uh
lipschitzness and i just wanted to
clarify
it's very different from relative
convexity
i mean there is this notion of relative
smoothness
and relative strong convexity and maybe
you can just comment on
how relative lipstickness is very
different from relative smoothness
right so in the case when the monotone
operator is just the gradient of the
comics function
our our uh condition
uh incorporates that of relative
smoothness so it
like this is actually like how we got
its name um but it
it turns out that like to to really
capture this uh
these more fine-grained analyses you
have like
there's like an informal statement we
make that like
relative smoothness is really a
condition between two points it's like a
integral
along like a line and then like relative
lipiousness like
sort of requires three points um which
is like why
the disorderization has to take multiple
steps um this
the same kind of phenomenon was found in
the um
was mentioned before in terms of
explaining acceleration and error
convexity and things like this so we try
to make it a little bit more formal
yeah very good i also have a kind of
silly question um how do i ask questions
in the q a or maybe i can just you you
can just pick up we don't need to ask
them
yeah yeah absolutely yeah i i i had a
question for robin um oh
really uh really awesome talk um so i
was wondering
in the model you're considering um is
like uh
is your heart family also a hard family
for classical algorithms like
is uh is uh is the
in the model is like can quantum
algorithms simulate all classical
algorithms so that
this would immediately follow yes yes
yeah the model is i guess correctly
defined so the quantum algorithms will
uh be able to simulate classical
algorithms
and so the same lower bound of course
also holds for classical algorithms
like one question i have is like robin
like are there
i mean is that the end of the story like
uh quantum just doesn't work for convex
obligation or do you think that there's
some good class of problems where i can
get big speed ups or
uh oh yeah certainly not the end of the
story in fact this is like uh
as i said it's like like chapter one or
chapter two of seb's monograph
that's all i've read so far but like
there's many different settings to
consider
this is like the most basic assumption
you can make on a function is just all
that you know is it that it's slip
sheets
the like the next assumption you could
make which is also very reasonable is
you can assume it's smooth
and then it turns out that even gradient
assign is not the class
optimal classical algorithm it's
accelerated rating design
and actually in this case we can also
prove uh yeah we haven't put this out
yet but we can prove that
there's no quantum speed up over
accelerated grading just when you assume
the function is smooth
so that's another case we've ruled out
but you can assume so much stuff but i
mean you can assume higher order
smoothness
this we're not sure what happens um or
you could assume more specific structure
on the functions right like
this is probably getting closer to
reality where maybe the function is the
sum of simple functions
or maybe you know something else about
it like you know maybe it's a neural
network that you're trying to train
um yeah we can view this as just like we
asked the most basic question and
got a negative answer but it's no reason
to be uh
yeah disappointing for the smooth case
is there at least another algorithm that
looks substantially different than agd
that gets the
quadratic speed up like using
powerful quantum tools oh uh
i that's an upper bound question that's
not really the question yeah that's a
really interesting question
uh i i don't know if there's a different
quantum algorithm like a genuinely
quantum way to get the
accelerated gains speed up uh although
there could be um
because some of the intuition that gives
you the accelera
acceleration and gradient descent like
you could say you know there's a
quadratic speed up going on
inside accelerated gradient design and
you could say it's the same quadratic
speed up that happens in grover's
algorithm which is like
the most famous quantum algorithm so so
there could be a way to somehow
get accelerated and descend in a
genuinely quantum wave but um i don't
know
there's also this original motivation
for accelerating this end with like some
with a heavy ball falling in a potential
and so on and this was also inspired
somehow by
classical physics so you might think
there's some quantum way to either have
hdd but i don't know anything that would
that would be fun
yeah it'd be cool
of course the physics intuition was
wrong and you know pollyak's momentum
does not work and does not give you
acceleration the whole point was to fix
physics
kevin i have another question so in your
talk uh you know you mentioned that your
framework is unifying but does it also
give you new application
um right so that's uh yeah
we're exploring we're not it's an
ongoing exploration yeah so
uh so far it seems to just yield like
known rate like known rates in a new way
but we think it might have cool
applications for um
uh like mini max optimization and things
like this oh yeah and actually for the
first question i asked i wanted to ask
just a follow-up
so you say you know i understood your
answer but
does it does relatively cheapness
formally imply relative smoothness
oh i see um so of course not the other
way but uh
sorry let me think about that right so
if
no i think it's it's a weaker condition
yeah um i think you can be relatively
legit without being relatively smooth
yeah yeah
oh you can be relatively difficult
without like if you are relatively
smooth you are also relatively shoots
but oh yeah of course of course of
course yeah yeah okay okay
because we don't we cannot get
acceleration for relative smoothness
right right exactly yeah okay perfect
very good excellent
uh okay another question from uh my
young
what the discretization applied in
quantum query models that converts
the continuous quantum spaces i'm not
sure i understand the question but maybe
you do
yeah i'm not totally sure what uh
they meant yeah maybe they could clarify
sure
is
is my aunt here so i have another
question in the meantime if mayank wants
to clarify uh by writing
um for cush actually so
in in your talk when you talk about this
comparison based uh algorithm and the
and the result for them um one issue is
that you're not gonna be able
like if you if you think about real uh
machine learning application where you
try to train
those deep neural networks using
gradient descent et cetera you're not
going to be able to run those algorithms
even using the k the k comparison
oracle with a large k right
so um i i mean the way
that our estimator works it's it's like
in the first step there has been just
this
estimation of the utilities part and the
next step is just
like solving the erm problem so once you
have the estimates it
i mean you can actually use any sort of
gradient design or any kind of neural
network problem to
solve those kind of uh optimization
problems so
rs in the first step is where you need
to interact with the comparison oracle
to just
get information about these underlying
utilities but the next step is just an
erm optimization problem which
i guess you can have the script f being
a
neural network and doing optimization
over that for the
next step so that couples well with the
i mean that's why our estimator was such
a simple estimator that
you can couple it with uh existing
techniques to solve
for the second part i see okay
well i i can try to answer the question
as best i understand i think
the question is basically about like how
you define this um
oh okay there is a clarification post it
says to clarify the discretization
required from a practitioner's
perspective
which is required to solve uh i see yeah
so
i guess you know even even classically
like you don't really want to think
about
getting real valued answers and inputs
and so on because
you know you're trying to do this on a
computer and like everything's discrete
and so on
um so to handle this like because we are
proving lower bounds
we we actually just assume that
everything is available to arbitrarily
many bits of precision it's not going to
matter
for us because our result would only be
stronger to handle this case
but i think the more realistic way to do
it is you assume that
all your uh oracle responses only come
out to so many bits of precision
but you just choose this number of bits
of position to be some somewhat larger
than anything that's relevant so
uh let's say like polynomial in all the
parameters that are involved in the
problem so that
now it doesn't matter that the fact that
you're um
only truncating it uh but yeah for the
purpose of our lower bound we just
assume you you can ask for arbitrarily
many bits to the oracle you can say give
me you know eight billion bits of
precision for this query and the oracle
will give it to you
and we're just drawing lower bounds so
so it's okay
maybe one last question for for cameron
um
do you have any conjecture or guess for
the low rank diagonal
um yeah man we worked on that for a long
time but i don't feel like we're great
at proving complexity lower bounds
i feel like it probably conjecture it's
hard
yeah we tried to prove that it was hard
for a while because
we yeah we know how to give like um
runtimes that are exponential in the
rank k
so it's not hard in the sense that it's
exponential in n or anything like that
um but we couldn't get a lower bound but
i think it's hard
but it's kind of surprising because it's
a super simple
um problem wait i sorry i'm super
confused by something
what happens for by criteria for the
diagonal
so for a diagonal plus low rank if i
have
if i allow myself rank k over epsilon
then
i'm able to get a low rank approximation
that's within additive
epsilon times the forbidden storm of the
optimal rank k
so i only need rank like k over epsilon
um
and you can use we actually have a whole
section of this paper that
tries to tackle that diagonal plus low
rank problem in the non-bi criteria
setting
and gets things that are like
exponential and k over epsilon but
we couldn't go beyond this and we also
couldn't prove hardness and the k
prime which becomes k over epsilon does
it follow from the communication
complexity
yeah so that becomes so it's actually
literally like 32k over epsilon
and this comes from the fact that the
communication complexity of inequality
is like
5 log base 2 of 1 over epsilon or
something
and so when you raise 2 to that power
you get like 32 over epsilon this
multiplies your rank
that's quite beautiful nice yeah so it's
actually in
the so i think yeah if i remember
correctly if you have an exact
low rank plus diagonal decomposition
meaning i can adjust the diagonal my
matrix to make it low rank
this problem has a name that i can't
remember right now it's not like
it has a name it's been studied and in
that case under some
relatively like weak assumptions you can
solve it via convex relaxation
um but without those assumptions we
still even when you have an exact
weight if it's exactly we don't we
you're saying you still need
extra assumptions if it's exactly yeah
like
i don't we don't even know how to do it
if it's exact which is kind of crazy
so that might be an easier case to try
to tackle
okay very interesting i mean i would
have imagined that if it's exact
okay i don't know i mean you would think
what you you would want well yeah the
rough idea what you would want to do is
you
want to find full rank blocks of the off
diagonals
and and then propagate then you could
fill in the on diagonals if you found
four right blocks the off diagonals
um but the trouble is like finding those
four ranked blocks
um is difficult
yeah i i think i understand cool
great yeah yeah anyways yeah
okay if there is no more questions thank
you everyone and we have one more
session of itcs
so feel free to hop on to room b
thank you very much again thank you